Я думаю, що наявність певного роду
миротворчих сил, які можуть виконати
угоду, як у Мінську, дає нам шанс.
Українські солдати
гинуть щотижня, люди отримують поранення, ми
хочемо зупинити це, але ми хочемо зробити це
і ми хочемо зробити це  таким чином, щоб
не заморозити досягнення Росії в Україні,
справжній ключ полягає в тому, щоб мати силу, яка
заслуговує довіри, тому ми повинні вибрати правильні
країни, які будуть дуже професійними,
дуже здібними, сильними, і ви бачите, як
ці сміливі чоловіки та жінки
спеціальної моніторингової місії ОБСЄ, ви бачите,
під яким тиском вони зазнають, тому ми
повинні переконатися, що якщо є
миротворчі сили або сили виконання,
вони повинні бути здатні
протистояти цьому, і ви повинні мати
дуже чіткі  правила бойових дій, ви
повинні мати справжню чітку систему командування,
і ви повинні мати справжню чітку
місію, а не просто розміщувати людей
у ​​блакитних шоломах, інакше це не
допоможе ситуації, я думаю, це
мало б бути п  країни НАТО,
тому що так, звичайно, я маю на увазі, що ви думаєте
про якісних солдатів, які прибувають зі
Швеції та Фінляндії, наприклад, жодна
Україна не має оборонної промисловості, яка б дуже
спроможна створювати якісні протитанкові
системи, тому я думаю, що, ймовірно,
варто постаратися  подивіться на свою
власну оборонну промисловість і скажіть, що ми, я
маю на увазі, що це чудова
неймовірна технологія, чому чому
Україна не виробляє власний джавелін, це
допоможе, тому що це найкраща
система танків у світі, і вона може
зробити це може посилити
Позиція України на переговорах